do you know any more about these two
missing men
first of all we are very much appreciate
to the British people and to the British
government about the very serious
support of Ukraine in this difficult
year we appreciate to the Andrew and
Christopher to their family because they
were volunteers to help and support with
the important humanitarian mission on
the east of our country in the most
dangerous region I mean
today it is their top temperature and
very difficult fighting there and we do
not have an information about the Andrew
and Christopher and I just want to
remind you that almost 8 000 Ukrainian
Fighters civilians are missing in action
only during this uh
War since the 24th of February and we
definitely confident that we should
unite the efforts and the law
enforcement agents of the Ukraine will
fight together for uh making freedom to
obtain any possible information about
these two hero and I want to make a
statement that this is the full
responsibility of the Mr Putin who
killing the civilians who stealing the
volunteers and who provide the murderous
methods of the war with that situation
this is definitely the evidence and you
see we have a problem with the light
this is just in evidence that Ukraine
and Kiev now is without electricity
we're sitting on the generator batteries
and with that situation this is not a
movie Mask to make any fear or to less
our decisiveness to reach the victory in
this war yeah
um
of course of course
um and you say that you're grateful for
the help you're receiving from outside
would you say that you uh welcome people
uh volunteers coming to uh help in a
humanitarian way in Ukraine like these
two young men or would you would you
warn against it because it is simply so
dangerous
hello
you're asking the wrong person because
I'm
every single week I am in the front line
I know what does it mean
and again we don't have a fear we are
not inviting those who have any doubts
to go or not to go but definitely we are
very much appreciate those people those
group those volunteers Who coming to
help support and help to survive
civilian on the newly deoccupied
territory on to help civilian elderly
people children who is now under the
disaster fire of the Russian troops and
we are very much appreciate and we are
welcome those who make a decision to
provide this humanitarian volunteers
Mission this is real hero
it is a very dangerous area as you were
saying uh just fill me in on the
situation at the moment is it your
understanding that Russian forces are
now in control of of solidar and almost
in control of of bakmut what is the
latest
uh the this morning I called to a member
of my team who is now in the uh
different Brigade who is fighting in
Soledad
this is definitely that this is under
control of Ukrainian troops fully
control we provide even the offensive
operation
solidar situation is more difficult uh
the fighting is inside the cities and as
president zelianski said that this is
the responsibility of zelenski that he
do his best to protect solidarity and we
definitely
help and keeping the unity for
protecting that but even if the Russia
has a tactical uh results on solidar
this is definitely not changing the
situation in the nearsk region and the
all east of Ukraine and we at the same
time provide in the offensive operation
in Criminal Minds whatever and the
Russia cannot do anything serious in all
Ukrainian territory and in donbassy in
particular so so how important is it for
Britain to supply Hanks directly to
Ukraine because we've heard that the
British government is now seriously
considering that
first of all I want to thank Sky News
because yesterday the Sky News was the
first who informed that the plan of the
British government was to supply the
Challenger to tanks to Ukraine this is
vital that during the winter spring
offensive operation tank is the
instrument for the Ukrainian offense on
the East and on the south at the same
time I want to thank the British
government and British people because my
charity organization bring from Great
Britain the military trucks the Spartan
and personal carrier the generator and
many many others and this is I really
appreciate that we have a such a great
cooperation with Great Britain with
British people and British government
who issued a license for my organization
to supply it to Ukraine and please pay
attention that the on the 20 20th of
January in Ramstein it would be
the anti-pooting Coalition meeting with
the purpose to finalize the question to
supply tank both British Challenger and
German Leopard II
and saman personal care including the
Bradley including French
German and personal career and this is
provide to equip the new create and
Brigade in Ukraine because we don't need
mobilization we have a long list in line
for enrolling to Ukrainian Armed Forces
with the Ukrainian volunteers but we
definitely need the weapons that with
the weapons in the hand we stop Russian
troops and I just want to remind you
that this is not just an assistance of
Ukraine this is the investment in the
European Security in British Security in
Global Security and this is definitely
very efficient step